hi there i'm marine wilson and i'm reza
aslan and rayne
i think you're beautiful well i guess i
think you're beautiful too reza thank
you that didn't sound nearly as certain
well i'm just starting to wrap my head
around that what do you find beautiful
about me let's start there i find your
moral and artistic light beautiful not
my beard
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
hello metaphysical milkshake listeners
here we are rain and reza and reza
listen we're both artists we're both
creators we're both storytellers among
other things you also happen to be an
academic in an author
but
you could argue that we've lived our
lives in pursuit of some kind of beauty
yeah physical beauty artistic beauty
moral
beauty yeah but what does that mean
exactly i guess it depends on how you
define
what is beautiful yeah in preparation
for this podcast on beauty today i i was
very flummoxed by it i i i haven't you
know truth be told i haven't done a
bunch of studying about aristotle on
beauty and socrates on beauty and plato
um
so i i i'm a little bit at a loss but
there seems to be a lot of connective
tissue between a lot of different big
key concepts and beauty yeah i've done
most of my studies have been on l'oreal
and beauty
and
not revlon a lot of yeah i've done some
i've done a bit of undergraduate but
this is one point because a lot of
people hear the word beauty and they
think beauty industry instantly you know
they think makeup and they think models
and instagram models and then i guess
people like you and me are supposed to
poo poo that and say
that's that's external beauty that's not
real beauty but
this is this is a this is a kind of a
moral burden for me so i'm gonna admit
something uh
a few years ago my wife and i were in
the middle of a conversation and she'd
mentioned something about the fact that
you know most of my closest friends
are
physically attractive men and women and
it suddenly made me go into this kind of
deep dive into my psyche
and then i had to kind of admit
that
yeah that's true that
uh
the the friends that i have in my life
that i am closest to
also happen to be maybe it's on purpose
maybe it's accident causation
correlation who knows
i also happen to be attracted to them
whereas the flip side of that is i've
had friends that i've known for a long
time yeah that i spend a lot of time
with
uh that i've had you know emotional
experiences with
but
if i'm being honest i'm not really
attracted to them physically and so
they'll never sort of rise to the upper
echelon of my closest friends wow i know
it's it's it's it's a kind of an awful
thing to admit something
i've got some a couple of big mammoth
whopper questions for you around that
that's quite a thing to admit and we're
brave to admit number one where do i fit
into this
you're the very top okay that's so not
true but number two are you just
admitting your own superficiality i i
don't know
well maybe there's some maybe there is a
correlation is there something that if
you have a friend that you've been
through hell and back with and you're
close and you work together but they're
physically not attractive or they don't
smell right or or something like that
like does that truly keep them from
being kind of more intimate with you
well i don't know if there's like a
biological or psychological reasoning
behind it all i can say is
yeah
can i can i uh be an armchair
psychologist for a minute boy here we go
you're an immigrant kid
you moved to oklahoma
um you're a pretty good looking guy i
think a lot of people don't know that
like you see reza it's like oh he's
actually a handsome handsome dude and
you're trying to fit in yeah and there's
some kind of like sociological
psychological impulse to fit in better
by hanging out with the better looking
kids better looking kids are more
popular but for you this is really life
and death it's not just like oh i want
to be approved of by my junior high
school friends like this is fitting in
for you the stakes are way way high you
know you've got a a farsi family you're
in you know middle america
so is this does this come from some kind
of like impulse of your some adolescent
impulse to to find your group because
the stakes are so high well these are
all really complicated questions i mean
beauty is is there a connection between
uh you know the the the attractedness
that you feel towards someone you know
in a platonic sense and their beauty
is there even an objective beauty or is
all beauty subjective
is it is there moral beauty and physical
these i mean these are these are the
kinds of questions that like you know
that the whole
your entire freshman experience in
college i think i just summed up in
those five questions yeah i mean is love
beauty is beauty love what's the
connection you talked about moral beauty
can you be beautiful on the inside our
culture doesn't really respect that so
much not really it's about external
beauty far more i wish one of us was
related to somebody who could answer
some of these questions for us what are
we gonna do
wait is your wife is your wife free no
she's not
wait a minute hold on you know who just
landed in los angeles my uncle
from lewiston idaho from lewis clark
university dr rhett diesner uncle rat um
he's a professor of psychology and he's
the author of the upcoming book it's
more of an academic book but it's called
understanding the beauty appreciation
trait empirical research on seeking
beauty in all things
he also did a tedx talk in 2013 about
beauty
which encapsulates a lot of his
philosophy and uh he's a brilliant
psychologist and psychological thinker
uh you know i've been super close to him
since i was a teenager um we're very
very good friends and i was really
excited to have him be part of this
podcast and maybe he'll share some
embarrassing childhood stories oh
wow let's listen to uncle rat
[Music]
after my master's degree i spent a
little time meditating on
what did the world really need and what
did i have to offer and what was really
important and i thought well
morality is really important i mean the
big decisions in fact the question i'm
even asking myself at that time was what
should i do and should some moral
questions so i thought well
who's the greatest
psychologist studying morality and it
was goldberg at harvard so i applied and
got to go work with him and how do you
make that shift from
more moral studying morality of
psychology or psychology and morality
and education over to beauty well
uh beauty and morality are very closely
linked
in fact my favorite existential
psychologist narala may says that
plato you know held beauty up as a
standard for both truth and the good to
meet because uh it was the harmony of
beauty that would let you know whether
you had truth value or moral value
and and of course aristotle very uh
clearly said that you know beauty is all
about
one's uh morals and values uh that you
know it's internal beauty obviously
aristotle was very ugly
that's why he said that the real dog
real dog yeah yeah
he would walk down the street and they'd
be like they'd be like wow that guy's
beautiful on the inside
you better so
help me to understand this because i
don't get this at all how can someone be
beautiful on the inside
and is that just something we say yeah
exactly really yeah
yeah
well you know that takes me back my
master's degree program actually was
in a behavioral program and they made
fun of anything on the inside right i
mean emotions ha ha cognition the black
box oh silly psychologists thinking
they're studying something they can't
even measure
i think going back to aristotle as you
mentioned reza uh he emphasizes that all
of our character strengths everything
from our sense of justice to
courage to love to kindness
that tell us of those their goal their
end is always beauty
and um wait explain that i don't get
that okay how is the goal of kindness
beauty is it that is it that who you are
who you are on the inside comes out on
the outside or is it just the outside
doesn't matter it's all that you said
tell us is it all just uh you know an
internal uh uh function
well uh you know internal and external
are very useful ways of categorizing the
world but you know could well be a false
dichotomy i mean it's uh
it's like faith and deeds right i mean
if you got faith you do the deeds if you
do the deeds you probably got the faith
they're
you know fairly well linked
and i think that's the same way with
our insides whatever they are our heart
our soul our mind
and our behavior consciousness
absolutely
these two just reveal each other
bidirectionally
um but you know us mortal humans i mean
we're we're animals that have sensory
systems and we see people behave and
then we make inferences about their
insides
because the behaviorist we're right
about that it's pretty hard to measure
somebody's emotions on the inside
and am i am i right in saying that
there's been a lot of research done
lately saying
uh this notion that um if you are
someone
who
is primed to see beauty
in the world in nature in other people
in art
um
that there is a correlation between that
desire for
for beauty to to experience beauty and
uh the desire uh to be a better person
uh definitely on topic but maybe
slightly tangential to that complex
question
uh is the work of jonathan height who's
at nyu now and uh you know i was you
always wonder would be like like be a
biologist and discover a new animal
right well he discovered a new emotion
which really isn't true he discovered it
he just named it and did the first
empirical work on it about the year 2000
and that's the emotion of elevation
and that's a moral emotion and it's the
emotional experience you have when
you're observing moral beauty in action
so like you're saying when you see
someone out there do something loving do
something fair stand up with courage and
it moves you yeah that moving you is
what he named elevation and the
eliciting condition is always moral
beauty i mean what what is it that
happens when you confront that kind of
moral beauty like biologically what's
happening to you that then makes you
uh feel this sense of of elevation you
know that's the direction that
neuroscientists need to move on this but
there has been at least one study
jonathan height and his colleague i
think
i can't remember for sure maybe silver's
studied lactating moms and put them
under certain moral beauty non-moral
beauty conditions
and were able to establish the oxytocin
increased during the moral beauty
experience so when you're feeling
elevation you also have elevated
oxytocin which oxytocin is like the love
pheromone like connection bonding yes
you know the words for it this actually
is really fascinating because it's kind
of bringing me around to what i would
say is
the biggest question about beauty which
is is it objective or subjective right
am i wrong i would think that that's
kind of like the first question that you
you asked when you're in a freshman
morals class i would go with that and i
would say
is yeah is can
beauty be qualified as objective or is
it all beauty in the eye of the beholder
as they say right and and what is beauty
i mean what is it i always think of
beauty as aesthetics but all of a sudden
we started this conversation and it's
all about moral behavior and biology
which makes me think
is it
maybe objective like if honest if i look
at something that's beautiful yeah and
then looking at it suddenly i'm full of
oxytocin yeah uh
but that i mean so there's a biological
isn't there like an objective beauty
then
no take talk us from the verb here we go
maybe we should ask the actual expert
here quickly write down those eight
questions you guys just asked but uh
yeah they're pretty exciting questions
uh i'm sympathetic when people say uh
beauties and i the beholder because it's
really obvious you find something's
beautiful i don't and you find some
things not beautiful that i do
i just looked at rain and then raise it
yeah and uh
right so it you know it's easy to think
oh okay so it's just subjective um
but what it turns out uh most
philosophers um think that it's uh
simultaneously subjective and objective
so beauty and that's exactly what i
would expect a moral philosopher to say
cop-out no the
non-dichotomous thinking please
and
uh beauty and the eye the beholder is is
very true in the sense that where does
the beauty experience take place well
you know it's taking place in your brain
if you're a materialist it's taking
place in your soul if you're
non-materialist it's maybe taking place
in both so it's easy to think oh that's
happening in me
but then you have to think well
something came at me i don't live in a
void what was that and that's the
objective properties of the beauty
experience and there's a long history of
that i mean i i totally idolized
socrates and he was a real objectivist
when it came to beauty for instance
and even the crazy wild uh crispin
sartwell who has the entry on beauty and
the stanford encyclopedia philosophy
uh he's an objectivist as well
um what do i mean objectivists it means
there's there's real beauty out there it
doesn't matter if you think it's
beautiful doesn't matter i think it's
beautiful it's beautiful sunset on a
mountain range is just beautiful
beautiful every seven billion people on
the planet there's not even going to be
a chance they'll be an [ __ ] who's
like
but no everybody yes i i'm with rain on
this like you know a beautiful uh flower
is just beautiful you know i mean so
there are things that are objective
those are nature things can can everyone
think that the acropolis is beautiful or
the mona lisa we're going to leave this
as a potentially open question
hey milkshakers if you're thinking about
breaking some bad habits this year start
with this one
overpaying for your prescriptions that
sucks
to do that get in the good habit of
always checking good rx to help find the
best price for your prescription
medications now i used to go to just one
pharmacy not knowing that you know what
prescription prices can vary between
pharmacies by as much as a hundred bucks
that's that's true 100 bucks yeah that's
true
100 bucks
and you you might be overpaying
so i always use goodrx to instantly find
discounts and compare prices at all the
pharmacies in my neighborhood so even if
you're like me and have insurance you
should still check goodrx because can
often beat your copay you can use their
site or the goodrx app which you can
download for free
goodrx is free it's easy to use and you
can instantly save up to 80
that's a big percent raza plus here's
another thing about goodrx it's accepted
at over 70 000 pharmacies nationwide
we're talking cvs kroger walgreens rite
aids bonds walmart pretty much all of
them
uh and what's great about good rx i mean
at least for me it's that you know ever
i'm getting older so i'm getting more
and more prescriptions and you know it
starts to like add up after a while and
so being able to find a good discount
price for my prescriptions makes good rx
totally worth it so for simple smart
savings on your prescriptions check good
rx go to good r x dot com slash
milkshake that's good
r
x dot com slash milkshake good rx.com
milkshake
goodrx is not insurance but can be used
instead of insurance in 2021 goodrx
users saved an average of 79 on retail
prescription prices
oneskin is a longevity company led by a
team of five phds developing solutions
to prevent slowdown and reverse aging
one skin harnesses the science of aging
to develop products that extend the
length of time that skin is healthy and
youthful its topical supplement is a
daily moisturizer powered by their
proprietary peptide
os01 the first peptide scientifically
proven to reduce the biological age of
skin here's the thing about one skin is
that it's not
it's not a skin care company it's a
longevity company right that's how they
talk about themselves it's it's
fundamentally different from most of the
skin care companies because you know
they're founded and led by longevity
scientists not marketing experts
and
for one skin it's all about the science
it's founding team of phd-level aging
experts spent five years in the lab
researching skin and aging to discover
this os01 and develop their topical
supplement
and i'm talking about real science here
people
one skin has four patents two scientific
papers two clinical studies and one
secret algorithm wait a skin care
with an algorithm that they don't mess
around rain sign me up
no seriously they send uh samples of
this stuff and i have my one skin
on the counter of my bathroom and
you know i have this other moisturizer
from that's super expensive from my
dermatologist and i've totally put that
aside the one skin is way better it just
feels better instantly hydrates
my skin and face and now
i look you look fantastic i look all of
52. it's great stuff so visit
oneskin.commilkshake
and use the code milkshake for 15 off
your first purchase
the code applies to one-time purchases
and the first order of subscription
purchases that's o-n-e-s-k-i-n
dot c-o
slash milkshake use the code milkshake
for 15 off your first purchase
one skin
the great philosopher at princeton
neomas he he's down with plato with the
objectivist stuff so i'm just going with
you know the really lame authoritarian
approach to science hey these guys are a
lot smarter than me they think is
objectivist so
uh but as to proving it
uh yeah i don't know how we'd go about
that here's my absolutely uh non-uh
professional view of this is that
attraction is subjective
but beauty
is objective and i may be making i may
be making this up but
i feel like a while ago there was some
experiment that was done hopefully you
can help me out here uncle rat um
where
um
they showed people uh a bunch of faces
um and it was it was precisely this
attempt to say you know can there be
sort of an uh objective beauty when it
comes to
people and then they had the
participants i think rank you know how
beautiful they were but the faces were
deliberately designed to be either
symmetrical or asymmetrical in some way
and i think what they've discovered was
that
symmetry is there's a correlation
between symmetry when it comes to a face
at least yeah and beauty
am i making that one up too no that's
something sometimes i just i think that
was across all cultures that was yeah
and then there's uh studies that have
found that if you think that someone is
beautiful you're also likely to assume
they're smart ambitious and interesting
and immoral and you'll think that
they're moral well let me let me reply
to the subtext of what you were really
asking which is evolution and beauty
so
uh have we evolved to notice beauty uh
yes okay so uh what was what's adaptive
about noticing what purpose and the the
big consensus is in terms of nature is
the stuff that helped us survive
so it turns out and we have a bunch of
objective evidence about this from uh
research studies is we find
a vista beautiful and why is it vista
beautiful because you're up on a vista
you can see your enemies you can see
where the food sources are
you got all sorts of good issues going
on there for you uh what do we like we
like green stuff why green stuff
indicates water it increases animals and
it creates fruits and vegetables that we
can eat we like also have a river scene
in there or a lake obviously again we
need water to survive
so all of these things that uh we tend
to find but can't you say that's so
boring can't you just say that there's
more stuff
you know if you're in a in a nook or a
hollow or a chasm and you're looking in
front of you you're seeing a bunch of
rocks and some moss right yeah you're on
a vista you're seeing there's a panoply
there's more color
there's more there's mountain ranges
there's trees like there's there's
something to the diversity of what
you're seeing yeah what about yeah like
i get what you mean with sort of the
greenness but you know we don't eat
foliage
do we we don't eat flowers but it's
indicative of where food might be i
guess i guess maybe i don't know isn't
there something to just a vista is also
beautiful because there's more things to
see in more interesting ways
well uh this an aesthetic to it it's not
simply uh behaviorist evolutionary
psychology preservations of the species
well this this is the way we think for
the last 75 000 years when the cultural
revolution started right and there's a
lot of critics of the evolutionary
approach to beauty because those things
may have applied and they may still be
roots and they may still be influencing
us but once culture came into play whoa
powerfully changed everything especially
our concepts of duty why is that because
is it because of um
[Music]
group think because one thing that i've
one one of the fascinating studies that
uh amy sent us about beauty
indicates that
ideas of what is beautiful could
actually spread like a virus would
spread that
if you have someone who finds something
beautiful whether you did before or not
you are more likely to then find it
beautiful yourself and is that
i mean is is that just sort of group
group think or is there is there
something biological happening you know
in you and you finding something
beautiful
and then meme
suddenly finding it beautiful as well
um and then that kind of concept of
beauty spreading and then we have beauty
within culture and then we as a
community decide oh
tall thin women are beautiful but then
another culture says no actually large
big boned women are beautiful and it's
just sort of a cultural thing yeah
yeah
yeah that's come into a play a lot and
uh you know you say there is a
biological component to it um in fact
one of the papers i wrote for journal
eco-psychology mentions me following my
dad around he was a nature lover and i
call it his gaze and his gate right what
he's gazing at he's not a man of many
words he didn't use the word beautiful
in front of me but when he's gazing
intently at something i mean what's a
four-year-old or eight-year-old going to
do they're going to look where they're
gazing and you're going to know that's
important and you're going to model it
on your mirror neurons something
important is happening right there he's
focused now he changes directions and
walks somewhere else that's his gait i'm
following
and so yes you know we
we are
not just herd creatures we're probably
hive creatures i mean we're really
designed to influence each other and we
do
going back to this notion of uh the
interrelationship between
uh
physical beauty external beauty and
uh internal beauty
we had talked about the fact that people
who are more beautiful are immediately
assumed to be smarter more moral and
then we've also talked about the fact
that uh
the sort of morality on the inside can
express itself
um certainly in the eye of the beholder
as beauty on the outside
but then
doesn't that just become an argument
for
sort of the beauty industry
therefore in other words therefore
shouldn't we all
try to be beautiful shouldn't i use you
know anti-wrinkle
medic medicine botox injections yeah and
bronzing
you know it's not actually it's not uh
it's not superficial anymore like i
actually if there's a link between you
know my morality and certainly the way
that people look at me then shouldn't i
try
to be physically beautiful
you know when you have a a multi-billion
dollar business in a capitalist world
they have a lot of powerful ways to
train us
to think what is beautiful and as you
mentioned earlier the contagion is huge
because that's the way we humans are
you know it reminds me of the time when
i was working in an education division
and we were thinking a couple of our
students smelled bad and you know maybe
they shouldn't be teachers because
they're gonna offend their students and
the parents and one of the kinesiology
professors what i used to call a be
teacher one of the kinesiology
professors says what what's wrong with
smelling like a human
and that's a life changer for me i
started thinking about that really we've
been all trained to think that human
sweat is bad and we need to clog it up
and disguise it and
really
so i don't think it would be that hard
for us to start thinking of beauty as
natural right i mean we could do the
same meme join thing and think hey
naturals cool do we really need these
body products uh because you know
they're stressful on the water systems
and
spoken like a true hippie yeah yeah
busted well okay so
um how can we then divorce
our
uh
sort of the the moral and ethical
spiritual beauty that we've been talking
about the internal beauty
um from our
day-to-day
uh desire to be physically pretty you
know
we've already said that they they're
linked with each other
maybe we don't want them to be linked
because of all the reasons that you said
so how do we de-link those two things
or can we well uh
i think one avenue for that
is uh
there are a couple of philosophers two
living sloth philosophers uh nehemos at
princeton and at crispin sartwell who
wrote the
beauty
section for a stanford university
philosophy book
uh they both say you know beauty's
everywhere and everything
and so it's becomes uh
a moral and intellectual challenge for
us to find it
and i think we can find that in people's
faces
i think if we look at anybody's face we
can find ways to construe it as
beautiful
um
and then
take some creativity
but it's possible exactly
i'm working on it
it's about the cultivation
of seeing beauty in everything yeah and
is that something you can get better at
like going to the gym and lifting
weights yeah can you make that muscle
uh stronger beauty muscle yeah yeah well
uh
it's not easy
um
if we if we
look at the most famous personality
theory it's the one on the five factor
model it's developed by mathematical
psychologists and it says basically our
personalities have to do with
introversion extroversion
conscientiousness neuroticness
agreeableness and openness
and you look at those big five ten
thousand published studies on them and
beauty appreciation and beauty fits into
the one on openness this is just
statistically true it might be
psychologically true but definitely
statistically true
and so
uh we can
uh as we develop our openness and this
is especially true of artistic beauty
the more open we become
the more we recognize artistic beauty
and when we really analyze artistic
beauty we're talking about design beauty
anything that has been designed can be
appreciated for its beauty or the lack
thereof
but we can still look for it and every
designer can be conscious of beauty and
designing this microphone right
designing our clothes designing the
building everything designed has the
potential to be beautiful and we can
look for those beautiful elements
but research on the big five show that
if we purposely want to change
personality
it's hard it's not easy
and openness is the hardest one to
change
but there is evidence that it can be
changed
now in my own research what i've shown
is probably the most effective way that
somebody's tried so far could be lots
more effective ways we haven't figured
out yet
but it's doing a pretty simple simple
thing called journaling or die or a
diary
so like for my students taking my psycho
beauty class
once a week they need to write down in
their diary something they found that
was beautiful it was designed something
beautiful in nature something morally
beautiful they saw someone do
and a beautiful idea that's amazing what
a cool assignment i want to do that in
my real life yeah
have you ever spent hours googling how
to care for your pet everything from why
is my cat sneezing so much or what to do
when your dog eats a stick of butter one
time
this is a true story a dog of ours ate a
box of condoms
yeah my dog enjoys his own poop
oh
yeah we've got one like that yeah
so skip crowd sourcing recommendations
from forums social media or trial and
error and get answers immediately with
fuzzy you see fuzzy is a telehealth
service for pet parents it offers 24 7
access to personalized pet care from
veterinary professionals from everyday
questions to middle of the night
emergencies fuzzy has the answers pet
parents need through live chat and
virtual vet consultations available to
you 24 hours a day 7 days a week fuzzy
can answer your pet questions big and
small urgent and every day
fuzzy can also recommend the exact right
products for your pet all of which are
hand-picked by their established team of
veterinary professionals and available
at discounts exclusive to fuzzy members
from getting your pet's diet just right
to meeting their middle of the night
needs to finally figuring out what makes
their breath smell that way poop it's
the poop it's always the poop nothing is
too big or too small for a quick fuzzy
call
no but seriously like this this eating
poop thing is a problem and i i
consulted fuzzy i've got a fuzzy account
and i got some really good advice right
now fuzzy's offering our listeners a
free seven-day trial membership go to
yourfuzzy.com
meta today to sign up that's a free day
seven day trial at y o u r
f u z
your fuzzy dot com
slash meta m e t a and for a limited
time fuzzy is also offering a special
discount of 20 bucks off any of your
pets product needs that's pet meds
supplements food whatever all you have
to do is use the promo code meta m-e-t-a
that's your fuzzy dot-com
slash meta for your free trial of fuzzy
with access to 24 7 personalized pet
care and vet recommended products
including products that will get your
dog to stop eating his own poop nordvpn
is a secure way of preventing your
personal information from being spread
around the web when using wi-fi
the line of protection is wonderful it
prevents spam viruses and other unwanted
privacy intruders and let me tell you
this is a service that you need if
you're like me i take my ipad everywhere
like i'm in a coffee shop i'm at
starbucks i'm at the restaurant and i'm
just like plugging into random wi-fi's
and i don't know if i can trust these
systems i don't know
who is listening in or or peeking into
my web searches and so that's why i use
nordvpn because i can access content
from over 59 countries simply by
changing my virtual location with a
single click
we live in the us obviously but with
nordvpn we can be anywhere in the world
and access content from any of those
regions so when we're traveling we're
using these insecure restaurant or
airport or hotel wi-fi's which are
notorious for stealing identities
nordvpn is a great way to protect you
and prevent hackers from stealing your
information you can use nordvpn for up
to six devices laptop phone
smart tv reza's ipad etc also i love to
use nordvpn to gain access to my
favorite tv shows in other countries
peep show peaky blinders
via the original perhaps you can also
get
uh
the office on canadian netflix
which usually is geo-blocked so
win-win-win
go to nordvpn.com milkshake or use code
milkshake to get up to 70 off your
nordvpn plan plus one additional month
for free it's also risk free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee
nordvpn
i gotta put a little jingle tag i like
the jingle tag
so what are you talking about for those
listening going oh that's a beautiful
idea well uh
for instance uh do you have a favorite
quotation from the quran do you have a
favorite quotation from christian
scriptures and evangel
you got a favorite quote from the torah
uh
have you ever had it
the golden rule is a beautiful idea
boomo you get your first week done on
beautiful idea yeah because it's uh it's
it's universal it's you can't prove it
wrong
it applies to everyone theist or
atheists yeah
look at that even got reasons for your
beautiful idea wow
fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]
all right lightning round
when do you feel most connected with the
universe
when i'm walking in a forest or when i'm
praying or both describe your soul in
ten words or less
um some kind of magical mystical thing
that's somehow associated with my body
and incorporates attributes of god like
love and justice that's exactly what i
would imagine a professor
would say just yeah but he'd blow
through the ten words but he did it like
seventeen words
yeah anyway he can't even follow the
assignment what do you think is the
purpose of your life to understand the
universe and to serve it
what uh
is your biggest fear
long slow death of great pain
yeah tell me about it
what's one thing you know for sure i'm
going to go socratic on this and say how
much i don't know
that's a cop-out that's a cop
we're going to let them happen
unbelievable what do you want your final
meal to be
oh never
[Laughter]
and finally what is your life's big
question
what's it all about really
well dr rhett diesner uncle professor
dear friend oh shucks beautiful
middle-aged man
beautiful almost senior citizen it's
been such a pleasure having you on the
show
i i've learned so much and uh this is uh
this is gonna be such a great episode
yeah i'm really excited to uh interview
the rest of brain's family
and that's that's basically what we're
gonna do this podcast on now cool we
gotta get my uh my uncle doug who uh
buys and sells heavy machinery ooh
that's that's a very metaphysical let's
let's get him sounds heavy
thank you rhett my pleasure
[Music]
so i really love this exercise that
uncle rhett talked about uh that
journaling exercise in his psychology of
beauty class let's remind everybody
about it one more time four things what
are they something beautiful in nature
yup
something beautiful that's artistic or
something that's been designed yeah
right
something that's morally beautiful like
for instance a kind of human behavior
yeah the human behavior you witness
right and finally a beautiful idea and i
love this final one um
notating every week a beautiful idea
that could be a new idea or an age-old
human idea and just a reminder that this
so uncle rhett basically is saying that
if you do this once a week then it's
like it's like exercising a muscle
you're cultivating
your appreciation for beauty which will
cultivate your ability to love to
empathize to empathize feel compassion
for the other to unite things
and uh and help make the world a better
place so all right so let's do this okay
let's do this you and i as an exercise
uh you go first something beautiful in
nature you want to share yeah uh just
this morning i went outside and uh i had
to clip the
uh the bushes in our front yard they've
got these beautiful yellow flowers on
them and kind of you know this rain of
beautiful yellow flowers came down on me
so it was beautiful
my wife and i took our honeymoon in
central oregon and we've really fallen
in love with this area of central oregon
near bend but up closer more in the
mountains three sisters mountains etc
when i go up there and i see the vista
of the three sisters mountains from the
little town of sisters oregon
i get a feeling in my chest
that
it it stops me in my tracks i've seen a
lot of beauty in this world and i've
appreciated a lot of it um but for some
reason when i see those mountains and
they're just spiky and covered in snow
and
um
the way the light is up there it it it
really like thumps my heart and there's
so many times i would say every time i
take a trip up there at some point in
time i just pull over the car to the
side of the road and i just have to just
stop and take it in and i try and
photograph it but a photograph never
captures the feeling of that
magnificence i love the three sisters
that's a good one yeah wow
[Music]
let's see something beautiful that's
artistic or redesigned well i just
returned from a week with my wife uh in
bali
and we there are you know there are a
lot of temples what i love about bali is
that there are just temples every five
feet wow but they're like actually still
functional temples they're not they're
not meant for tourists like there are
actually signs that say please don't
enter but there's one temple especially
it's called the tirtaganga water temple
and it's this amazing former like royal
palace and and there's water everywhere
and you kind of there are these um
stones that come up out of the water so
you can walk on them and it looks like
you're walking on the water it was just
just absolutely gorgeous that that that
really hit me this last week
what about you something beautiful
artistic or designed yeah i had a
i had a spiritual experience of beauty
when i saw
in
real life
a very famous painting called luncheon
of the boating party by renoir
i was walking through uh the corcoran
gallery
in washington dc i was doing an acting
job there and i just turned my head down
um a hallway
and this luncheon of the boating party
was sitting there and it stopped me in
my tracks my jaw dropped i i couldn't
believe that
it's pigment on canvas right but light
seemed to be emanating from it it was
like one of those paintings you felt
like you could walk into and it had such
um
a langer and life and conviviality and
connection between the people and
i just wanted to be in that painting and
uh it was really a very powerful
experience and it actually got me
thinking a lot um in my kind of
spiritual and artistic life about that
combination of spirituality and artistry
and how how is it that a some dude in a
beret with a palette of paints was able
to
blob this paint down on an empty canvas
and make something that was so powerful
and alluring and and mesmerizing that
seemed like it was glowing and i thought
there is a miracle in that act there's
literally talking about jesus walking on
water miracles that is where the
miracles lie
[Music]
uh let's see i think the third question
was something that's morally beautiful
yeah you have anything like that what do
you got again oh you know i was gone for
a week came home and my four-year-old
has not
left my side since i've been
home he just i mean just
physically connected to me for the last
four or five days we sleep together we
he he's on my lap when we eat and
there's and he just keeps every once in
a while just looks up at me and and says
i love you bubba it's just like this
like seeing that kind of
you know there's a purity adulterated
pure love right that he that he shows me
it's um yeah it's just it's just the
greatest thing in the world well going
for this last week i went uh yesterday
to climate strike friday's for future
with greta dunberg downtown at city hall
and um
i don't go to a lot of marches and
rallies and whatnot but there was
something really morally beautiful about
people that cared so much about the
planet that they sacrificed
their entire day
to be a part of it
and it was very diverse which was really
beautiful to see people of all different
genders sexualities races uh classes um
students there were inner city barrio
kids and
native americans and it was had
beautiful diversity and
i thought that was a really
beautiful human behavior to witness that
[Music]
and finally the last one uh and really
the most striking of all of these a
beautiful idea has there been a
beautiful idea that you've been uh that
you've come up against
okay so last night i took a bath a
really long hot bath and i i tend to
like get in a bath and then just like
lose all time and then eventually i
start to get
weak and dizzy and so i was coming out
of the bath and i lay down on the ground
uh to just sort of get cool a little bit
and i noticed that
i was kind of splayed on the ground and
my
hands and my legs
happened to just kind of point towards
the bedrooms
of all of my children including the
bedroom that will become
uh the room for my next child
your forthcoming channel we just keep
popping them out
and uh
long time listeners know i have 17
children um and uh i'm just kidding i
have
soon to be four children
and um
and there's some stress involved in that
you know financial stress a lot of
anxiety uh about like rolling in podcast
kids
that's true i forgot about that and um
and then i had this moment and i don't
think i've actually
we'd weirdly enough have have had this
moment or at least been aware of it uh
where suddenly
i felt so
proud of myself
so this beautiful idea is the creation
of a family and the bonds of family yeah
and just like you physicalized it i did
like look at this i i like i did this
all by myself my wife had nothing to do
with it uh i i
i wrought this thing look at me with my
gigantic
family it was it was just it just made
me feel really it was just beautiful it
made me feel really good that is a
beautiful idea that really is and then
and then uh and then uh my wife from bed
yelled at me what are you doing out
there you're keeping me awake and i was
like
okay beautiful ideas
broke time
well i can't top that one that was
really uh beautiful and special but i
think the
again with the climate march i was
thinking about the diversity there and
i'm talking a real diversity i mean
obviously it wasn't like there weren't
republicans there sorry but um
uh but there were suburban housewives
you know and there were rich people in
their teslas there and there were poor
college students eating ramen um
and i really love this idea of unity in
diversity and this is a key idea in the
baha'i faith and one of the things that
really attracts me to the baha'i faith
is that
humanity is a
variegated flower garden and it's in
diversity that we find strength not in
kind of
unanimity is that the right word
so
i really love the strength of that idea
and moving forward humanity to survive
on this planet is going to need to
embrace its diversity and for you reza
that yes that does mean conservatives
that we have to find but it doesn't mean
unattractive people
no they should be
they should be put on another planet yes
yes um so that was this was fun
so listen up listeners it's your turn
okay we want you guys to do the same
thing and whether you do it every week
like uncle rhett says to do or whether
you do it once
do it write it down four questions
something beautiful in nature something
beautiful that's artistic or design
something that's morally beautiful like
human behavior and a beautiful idea
treat
beauty like a muscle that you can
exercise and you'll get better at it
hey milkshakers
it's me and reza here as you know we'll
have to bring fan guests on the show
with their life's big questions you can
hit us up on the social media
and
you can also leave a positive hopefully
review on apple podcasts with your
life's big question and we will track
you down and bring you on the show and
that is how we found natalie
gregory the hipster who has joined us
and uh i was saying she is the the
hippest uh
looking fan guest we've ever had we're
we're very grateful for that and i guess
even hipsters have life's big questions
too is that
am i being really mean and unfair i i
mean i guess these glasses pretty much
they do scream hipster for people who
they can't see they're chunky
like the old school buddy holly glasses
but you know it's it's fine it's good
all right i'm glad you're not insulted i
mean that in in a good way you've got it
you've got a excellent
look you've got a nice
you know it's like nerd nerd chic you
know nerd chic hipster i'll i'll take it
so natalie welcome to metaphysical
milkshake what is your life's big
question
thank you really happy to be here you
know i i'm so
i'm so excited to talk to you guys and
ask my question so i think that a lot of
life's big problems and
across history
um
well a lot of problems i think stem from
toxic masculinity but i'm not going to
get into that today because i think the
actual overarching problem is the ego
and so my question is how do we
conquer
the ego how do we live
free of fear and how do we live so that
we are not ruled by the ego when we make
these horrible decisions based on
basically out of fear
yeah um
i i love the question and i love how you
linked it to toxic masculinity because
ultimately it really is
at the root of that you know um
preserving our sense of self and um our
fear of losing what we feel like we have
and that we have under control
is at the core of
uh of toxic masculinity i know that term
can be questionable because it just
turns so many people off but
um
i'm not sure what other term to use
right now so we're going to stick with
that but this is like one of the central
spiritual questions of all time right so
oh yes is what the buddha was addressing
you know at 1000 bc of you know this
whole idea of the self um
you know in my tradition as a baha'i
i may have shared this story on here
before but i just love it so i'm going
to tell it again
um
a great spiritual leader in my faith
tradition whose name was abdul baha
he came to the united states about a
hundred years ago and a journalist asked
him
hey do baha'is believe in satan and
abdul bihar said yes
uh to the baha'is satan is the insistent
self
so that's a very interesting concept
that satan's not some dark lord who
lives in a hell somewhere and has got a
trident and is really mean and
whispering in people's ears but that who
is whispering in our ears is the
insistent self
you know and
this is this is a constant in the human
struggle this is kind of like
if you're going to boil it all down to a
core issue
it reflects in politics it reflects an
environment and it reflects in men's and
women's issues
and uh
and the buddha you know dealt with it
that
suffering is attachment and attachment
comes from the ego wanting to control to
clutch
and to own and to grasp and to
get more
things in transitory things so
um the root of all suffering really
hinges from the ego so if we tackle the
ego collectively all seven billion of us
we might actually be a happier species
and more harmonious species on this
planet yeah
of course the buddha's point was
there is no ego there is no self
because everything
is illusion
in my tradition
sufism
we we kind of we accept that yeah that
there is no self that that's the
foundation of
like true spiritual fulfillment like
true understanding
of
reality you know the world universe
begins
where the buddha began which is there is
no self
but
as opposed to the sort of buddhist idea
that there is no self because all things
are void
everything is an illusion
you know nothing is real
the sufi idea is no there is no self
because
the self is a drop of water in an ocean
right
like how do you differentiate that drop
from the rest of the water from the rest
of the water in the ocean you can't
it is utterly one
with the ocean it doesn't exist
as a singular drop any longer
um
and so it's that kind of idea of like
the notion that who you think you are
who what what your ego is is merely just
a part of a massive whole
but yeah i mean rain's right like
fundamentally you know that is the same
notion that the problem starts with the
self the problem starts with the ego
uh and that's a that's a
an issue that you can hear you know in
the east the west you know in ancient
religions contemporary religions it all
just kind of starts with the ego
so what's the answer to detach from it
is it just meditation do i have to just
do meditation
that's it's kind of funny
that's kind of the new age kind of
catch-all like yeah any issue you have i
have an eating disorder i'm depressed
dealing with ego like meditation
um i'm not going to go to meditation off
right off the bat what do you think
natalie what do you what are your what
are your thoughts you've got some
thoughts on this i i i say that because
i make fun of myself because i've tried
to cultivate a meditation practice and i
i haven't done a very good job but i do
think there is something to the idea of
separating from your thoughts because at
the end of the day i think ego is
sort of your thoughts or that's how it
manifests and so
detaching from thoughts i do think is
key
to
cultivating that sort of you know like i
was saying earlier not making any
decisions based on that so
well i don't know what do you guys think
well
i think meditation can be very helpful
um
in a number of different ways and on a
number of different levels but i think
even just having this conversation and
recognizing that there is an ego and
that we are not our ego we are not our
thoughts and we are also not our ego
meditation can certainly help with that
idea
but that we have consciousness
and part of that consciousness i would
say someone who occupies the chairman of
the board's seat in the conference room
of our consciousness
is
mr or mrs ego
and is if we're able to recognize that
as like a a
significant part of who we are but not
all of who we are then we get to see
when it flares up so then the ego flares
up like ah i can't believe they spoke to
me that way i'm never gonna call them
again oh that jerk and then all of a
sudden you go oh that's my ego talk it's
not actually me that's not actually my
consciousness
that's the ego chairman of the board
pontificating and blowing hard and
smoking his cigar and
i get to witness that and in the act of
witnessing i get to detach lovingly
from
mr or mrs eco and this is then an
ongoing process um
and but we have to have we have to
develop that sensitivity we have to
develop that awareness first and
foremost
well said well said partner
thanks
well natalie thank you so much for uh
joining us and thank you for your
thought-provoking question uh natalie um
are you in an insane asylum
i am in a wework phone booth
oh wow oh that makes sense
sort of sort of like
a different type
folks if you have a life's big question
uh you know what to do uh rate and
review us on apple podcasts ask us your
big question and if we like it we'll
bring you one like natalie uh in the
meantime
rid yourself of the ego
thanks natalie thanks so much for having
me guys it was a blast
thank you again to our guest uncle rhett
diesener tomorrow on metaphysical
milkshake we will hear from rayne's
cousins and then eventually my uncle
doug
and his heavy machinery any nephilim
operation any nephews nieces let's bring
them all in basically we got a lot of
these to do yeah we might just go
through your entire family let's do it
uh we'll catch you next week thanks so
much for listening bye
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsay cradwell sarah
pellegrini mary philip sandy and shelby
sandlin original music by jeff tang and
scott tang
[Music]
and i i just want to say that you know i
think it's a real honor to hang out with
two really beautiful minds and hearts
named uh rain and reza i like how you
only referred to our internal beauty
which is
i mean i just want you to know i noticed
i i appreciate that because i've been
working really really hard and trying to
find you beautiful
well it is an effort it's a struggle yes
that's why we're podcasters and we're
not on the air
we've got faces for podcasts
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you